and please God won't the pain stop won't
somebody think of the children okay I
spend a lot of my time doing this
and when we when I draw a diagram I'd be
very clear to talk is all about meaning
and so I want to be clear about my
meanings and how I draw diagrams and
what I show when I show an arrow like
this in a diagram of a microservice
architecture we're seeing here an arrow
going from one service to another and
this is denoting some form of logical
dependency what I'm showing you here is
not data flow because that kind of
implies that data goes One Direction
which it never does I'm showing here a
logical dependency I'm saying here that
the shipping returns microservice
depends on functionality provided by the
shipping microservice and when we think
about architecture at a logical level
when we're sort of abstracting ourselves
away from the underlying implementation
detail trying to get these logical
dependencies right to avoid things like
circular dependencies or services that
seem overly chatty or you know overly
kind of coupled this is a very useful
place to start
and at microservice architecture we can
Implement these dependencies in a number
of different ways but generically
speaking what we're saying here is the
returns microservice depends on
functionality provided by the shipping
microservice and that's what this arrow
is showing simple straightforward stuff
of course spending all of you know I
can't spend all of my time in the world
of logical architecture because you know
back in the sort of I would say late
1990s early 2000s you could make a very
good career as a highly paid our
software architect existing purely in a
space of logical architecture and never
having to solid your hands with things
like actually implementing the system or
understanding how code works that days
those days have gone thankfully we now
have to think actually about how we're
going to take these ideas and actually
Implement them so then people start
talking to me about well Sam how are we
going to communicate between these
things
are we using synchronous or asynchronous
communication and that's what this talk
is all going to be about
now I want to start off with an
admission I've always struggled with
this these two terms and I think this
talk today is really me trying to
summarize why I struggle with these
terms
when it comes to logical interactions
the concepts I found to be more useful
when thinking about the nature of
interactions between Services when I'm
trying to think about getting my
boundaries right is not to think about
synchronous and asynchronous but instead
to think about the differentiation
between request response or into
communication sometimes called request
driven or event-driven communication
and I think here the differential is
quite Stark and quite clear and as a
result is often a more meaningful way to
think about communication between things
probably the most common form of
communication that I see in an
inter-process context is request
response-based communication and this is
often because it's quite analogous to
calling a method on an object and for
many people they take an existing
monolithic application they break it
down into Services perhaps using
something like an RPC mechanism and that
kind of promotes this sort of request
response flow I have a service that
needs to accomplish something in this
situation here the return service needs
to facilitate a customer returning an
item and so it needs a postage label but
it cannot generate that postage label by
itself that's the responsibility of the
shipping microservice and so we send a
request we say hello
could I have a shipping label here's the
size of the package here's the weight
here's the destination and in this case
here the shipping microservice
understands all different courier
companies we might work with it selects
the right kind of label and it sends it
back and that is our response we often
talk in this context about the returns
microservice here being the consumer
because it is consuming the
functionality provided by another
microservice in request response or into
Communications quite conversational and
the consumer is driving the interaction
this is quite starkly compared to
event-driven collaboration
with event driven collaboration we start
with an event an event is omitted an
event is a fact it is a statement
something has occurred in this case here
the stock level has changed and it is
then up to other microservices to decide
if they want to react to that event and
if they decide they want to react to
that event they get to decide what they
do with that information in this case
here we have the promotions microservice
which is saying okay well I know that
when we reached our stock level hits a
certain volume I should automatically
discount the products because we want to
shift them out of our warehouse
whereas the wishlist microservice might
say well hang on okay I know all these
people were really interested in when
this new album came out so I'm now going
to email them and let them know that
their item that they had wish listed for
pre-order is now available and in stock
two different microservices here on the
right hand side are both the consumers
in this context they are consuming the
functionality but they don't initiate
this distinction for me has always been
quite clear and quite useful as a way of
saying what style of communication do we
want and I tend to start at this point
in fact once I've understood the nature
of the domain we're working on we start
sketching out our service boundaries
we're going to start thinking okay well
naturally with this type of interaction
are we drawn more in One Direction than
the other
and then we overlay other concerns on
top of this things like what are our
security concerns latency sort of just
throughput what technology do you
already have in the mix and how well
does the technology we have available to
us match to these styles
but very quickly the conversation comes
back to this
synchronous versus asynchronous but Sam
I want an answer because some people are
telling me that I'm a bad person for
using synchronous communication and I've
got to use asynchronous communication
because my hair will be long and glossy
I will be more attractive to the members
of the appropriate sex
I would have a spring in my gate
so trying to combine these models I
would often talk about how these ideas
combine I would talk about how with a
request response-based interaction it
can be synchronous or asynchronous in
nature and that once you decided to use
the questions bonds based communication
you still have another choice to make
which is which one of these
implementations would you prefer
event-driven communication I would
always describe as always being
asynchronous in nature if you're saying
I'm going to use event driven
communication you are naturally
gravitating towards asynchronous
communication
I kind of sort of still stand by this
kinda sorter
but the problem I've got and this came
up when I was trying to do the second
well and I was writing the second
edition of my book recently was
realizing that there is not any good
consistent definition of what the term
asynchronous means
and I was inspired to do this particular
talk partly because my challenge is here
but also partly by this post by Pat
Helen so Pat Helen is one of the
pioneers of computing you should read
his sub stack it's very infrequent but
it's always a very good signal to noise
ratio and in his particular article Pat
is trying to explore the term eventual
consistency and he makes the argument
that eventual consistency part of the
reason it can be so confusing is that we
use the term consistency in lots of
different contexts in Computing
but where that term has very different
meanings
so he actually argues in this that we
should probably prep better refer to
eventual consistency as eventual
convergence because eventual consistency
describes a system where eventually
every replica will converge to show the
same state
whereas consistency we often get
confused in terms of say the consistency
of an acid database transaction
and if you think you know what the
consistency of an asset database
transaction actually is go and now look
at the definition of it because it will
surprise you because it's not at all
what you thought
so I was struggling with this a little
bit and I thought well hang on can I do
a pat Helen
can I come up with a better term for
asynchronous communication
in short answer no because I'm not as
smart as him but at least want to take
you through my thinking so far because
maybe some of you will have a better
idea
now at this point what I would normally
do of course if I was sentiment and
smart is I'd do a huge amount of
research looking through lots of books
for prior art and I did a little bit of
that but I didn't do a lot of it because
I'm not Kevin Henny instead I relied on
Twitter because I am fundamentally at
heart lazy so I thought maybe maybe I
can get some sensible answers on Twitter
and obviously this being the pre-musk
days the answers were slightly more
sensible than they are today and so I
put this out there like a Batman
Spotlight only it's you know to my
followers which are largely other people
interested in
architecture and I said was this mean to
you what does our asynchronous mean to
you because I think the definition is
fuzzy
and I got a variety of different
responses
I'm going to take you through some of
them and take you through some of the
other research I did around this topic
and just share some insights around this
so on the first responses I got was from
Darren Hobbs who happens to be an old
colleague of mine he's based in the UK
and he said for him asynchronous
communication is about sort of sending
an email versus send having a phone call
and at first glance this feels like a
useful and interesting distinction
however it does imply some kind of
performance differential
phone calls are fast emails well how
many people here have got a zero inbox
right
yeah the people that have zero inboxes
they don't have very busy lives right
you know
but we know we don't respond to email
straight away so there's something
interesting here but it also sort of
implies a speed aspect which I don't
actually think stands up because
actually the most high throughput low
latency systems I've ever worked on
would absolutely be things that most
people would describe as being
asynchronous in nature
so that doesn't quite work so around
this time I started you know letting the
Twitter thread rumble on and picking out
interesting responses they came in so I
also started looking at prior art and
one of the more interesting pieces of uh
our out prior are out there is a thing
called the reactive Manifesto
so hands up if you have read the
reactive Manifesto
okay hands up if you signed it
hands up if you understand it
what one person right okay half half
understand it right so the first thing I
want to say is I'm about to tear this
apart but I'm going to start off by
saying I know some of the authors that
are active Manifesto and they're very
smart people who are respect greatly and
from whom I've learned a lot there is a
lot of stuff in the reactive Manifesto
that I find to be interesting and useful
however we have to accept it is a piece
of Dogma which is a very kind of
specific and extreme Viewpoint it is
also unfortunately not very useful for
you to understand how to build systems
because it is it's a little bit vague in
its definitions but let's get into that
and talk about it so I want to stay up
for this these people put hard work and
effort into creating something and
putting it out there and I'm going to
tear that apart a little bit so this is
done with great respect but at the same
time it's fun to poke holes at other
people's work so we'll start off with
their definition they've put some work
into defining the term asynchronous and
I thought great because these are smart
people I respect the work they've done a
lot so let's read what they wrote about
asynchronous
so this the entry goes the Oxford
English Dictionary describes
asynchronous as not existing or
occurring at the same time we'll come
back to that later on in the talk
in the context of this Manifesto
we mean that the processing of a request
occurs at an arbitrary point in time
sometime after it has been transmitted
from client to server
just go that one more time
the processing of a request
occurs at an arbitrary point of time
sometime after
it's been transmitted
from the client to the server this sort
of is using the language of request
response which is kind of odd because
really they talk about events but it's
that's a bit muddy but anyway the thing
that really stuck out with me is this
idea that things are only asynchronous
if the request is processed after it's
been received
and I'm like as opposed to what right as
opposed to the server processing the
request before it was sent
like I I don't know unless they got some
kind of Doctor Who kind of networking
protocol wiring on here
because Also let's remember the two
fundamental truths of distributed
systems
the first is that you cannot beam
information instantaneously between two
points in time
yes we understand that quantum
entanglement is a thing but quantum
entanglement is not a networking
protocol
so in that context we know we cannot
beam information instantaneously between
point a and point B therefore because
our universe is one in which causality
exists the request will always be
processed after it is sent unless time
travel is a thing so this is kind of a
meaningless term I mean it's definition
but it's other stuff in there and I said
is there is some great stuff in the
reactive Manifesto so I dug a bit deeper
and often it's easier to define a term
by talking about the opposite and this
can sometimes be a useful way of
understanding what something is
and they've actually done that as well
and this just starts to feel more
concrete to me and starts to give me
better understanding
so they're saying that synchronous is
the opposite of synchronous processing
which implies that the client only
resumes its own execution
once the service has processed the
request it's saying that synchronous
processing means that I can't do
anything until that other thing has
finished its request that's what it's
saying now actually this is a very very
specific thing that has a concrete term
and that term isn't asynchronous
and this came up back in the Twitter
thread so Steve Smith who's uh works for
equal experts over in the UK knows a lot
about continuous delivery very nice chap
he initially came back and said that for
him
synchronous versus asynchronous you know
he thinks synchronous communication for
him is like TCP
is a connection is open for the duration
of communication and again I like poking
holes at my friends so I said okay so
you say if I use quick or UDP what does
that mean and he clarified is what he
actually means
is that you're not blocking for a
response
so what the reactive Manifesto was
talking about and what Steve's talking
about is the concept of non-blocking and
that is a very specific concept which I
think is more useful to discuss than
talking generically about asynchronous
communication so let's talk briefly
about non-blocking calls
so we've got a very simple scenario here
we've got a micro service which is going
to be responsible for some kind of
business process so you can imagine this
is a simple little orchestrated process
here
and to carry out this operation I need
to go to a loyalty micro service and
give someone some points
I also want to upgrade their
subscription by talking to the
subscription microservice
now these calls are not don't need to be
causally linked I don't need to do one
and then the other they're not Linked In
and of themselves
but I do want to do both these
operations
now if I implement it is in a fairly
straightforward naive fashion I might
have a bit of code like this
so I have my first line of code which
makes the first call
and then I get back a response object
rest one when that when that call has
completed
so I make the call I wait until I get a
response I now have that response object
then I move on to the next line of code
here
and then I make the second call to the
other microservice
so I have to block and wait for the
first service to complete handling of my
request and to wait until I get that
response object back once I have that
response object then I can go on to the
next line of code this is what a lot of
people certainly a lot of people who
like the reactor Manifesto would decry
this is for them synchronous and
blocking
it definitely feels like it's blocking
right
so of course there are some inherent
challenges with blocking calls like this
although it actually is quite a as an
obvious starting point for a lot of
people building distributed systems for
the first time one of the bigger issues
here is around latency
so if you think about how long this
operation is going to take the duration
of this operation is now going to be the
sum of the calls
rather than being the maximum of the
longest call
so in this case here if we said that
arbitrarily the first call takes 50
milliseconds and the second call takes
150 milliseconds that means
that our operation is going to take at
least 200 milliseconds in total
and obviously this actually is in
reality would likely be worse
because in a real world system you
should never look at the average latency
you should always look at latency on a
histogram because tail latencies can
really screw things up and what you tend
to find is when you have a series of
sequentially blocking calls
you actually end up with a really large
variation in how long an operation can
take
and when you have a system that has
quite a large variation in terms of
healthy Behavior it becomes very hard to
actually manage that system
so we end up with a double whammy
problem firstly this thing is taking
longer than it needs to and secondly we
end up with a system that can be harder
to understand and that's not good
consistent behavior is often better it's
often significantly better than
sporadically fast Behavior that's also
sometimes really slow right you would
take a consistently mediocreally
performing system over extremes any day
of the week
but an obvious Improvement here is to do
these two calls in parallel so rather
than doing one line of code and
executing it and then going to the
second line of code instead what we
would like to do is to say well look
let's just make this whole thing faster
and let's basically run this in parallel
and this is actually very very easy to
do using things like reactive extensions
so in this example here we're going to
make a change
we're going to wrap the invocation of
these calls in a future so a future is a
read-only type
the value of which is dependent on a as
yet potentially uncompleted operation
so I'm making a call
but that call is effectively being
dispatched on a background thread
so if you see that first bit in the
parentheses there when I create that
future
I'm not blocking and waiting what's
happening behind the scenes is that call
to the service is being packaged into a
separate thread and run separately run
independently so it's now not blocking
this potential this bit of code
execution so in Java this would actually
end up being an operating system thread
so the nice thing about this is that we
can kind of train up a whole bunch of
calls
but we're not waiting for the first call
to finish we're immediately going onto
the second line the third line and we
can keep walking through in the
background these calls are now happening
in parallel and this is just obviously a
bit of pseudo code there's difference in
tactic sugar for different programming
languages but it's all pretty
straightforward to look at examples in
your own programming language your
choice
effectively though what this basically
means is all the code looks virtually
identical to the previous example
what's actually now going to happen is
that those calls will run pretty much in
parallel
assuming we've got spare threads and I O
capacity and everything else
so the hope would be that our the
latency of this particular operation
might go from being say 200 milliseconds
to now being 150 milliseconds because
we're able to paralyze the calls
so this is obviously an improvement
non-blocking seems great in this context
and in general I tend to agree but let's
poke a little bit deeper into the
concept of non-blocking
because it turns out that sometimes when
you ask a microservice for something or
any service for something you might
actually want the results weird I know
it's almost like that's the point of a
request response based interaction is
that you get the response and that
response may just be confirmation that
the thing worked but sometimes it might
be the data you requested
and sometimes it might be something like
an ID of a new resource that you've
created and you might need to do
something with that information
you might need to take the results of a
service invocation and use that result
so it's invocation for some other job
so we actually may need the results so
that gets tricky
because we come back to our previous
example if we're thinking about how the
code executes kind of a line at a time
at this point
neither of those calls may have
completed they might have finished they
may not have finished we just don't know
so we don't actually know if those
result objects are going to give us
anything other than I'm not ready yet
when I would try and access them
so what do I do
to get those results to actually get
those response objects from these
non-blocking calls
we have to wait
how do we wait for the results of a
non-blocking call we might do something
like this
so this is like an await and it is
saying block and wait until both of
these Futures have completed
so
we've got
a non-blocking
and therefore based on reactive Minister
festo asynchronous communication
that then has to block
so is this asynchronous or not
is it non-blocking or not
I don't think you can describe this
client as non-blocking I think you can
describe these particular invocations as
non-blocking but not the whole client
so this is again it's murky but I still
prefer I like the term non-blocking and
blocking when we talk about an
individual invocation to another service
it makes sense we can discuss it but
this idea that non-blocking is
non-blocking kind of not right so
even if you have non-blocking calls the
logic of your processing may still
require that you have to wait for things
to happen
even non-blocking calls can end up in
you having to block
but
they are still worth doing in my opinion
that confusion aside non-blocking calls
in general especially if you're starting
from a piece of code that looks like my
first example are often a good and easy
way to improve your program in terms of
speeding up performance
and also avoiding you having to do
anything crazy threading yourself and
the reactive extensions for all the
different programming languages out
there are really really good this is
actually one area where net led the way
so okay well this kind of was starting
to make concrete sense but I knew there
are other definitions out there so back
to the Twitter thread we go
so here is Graham Lee and Graham Lee's
uh used to work on Tyro which is a
payment system and Bank in the U in
Australia it's worked on big complex
systems before
and so Graham was sharing his thoughts
he said okay the definition that he's
been using is the sending service
doesn't wait for completion of the
receiving service before continuing and
or completing its own work this is
non-blocking again that first little bit
there is non-blocking
but now I think about it I also expect a
temporal decoupling
from the receiving Services availability
this is a new thing whereas we've
introduced a new term temporal
decoupling
and what this describes is a situation
where
when I talk to another service
if that service isn't available and that
means that I can now carry on with my
work I am temporally coupled you have to
be up and available at the same time I
am for this operation to work
temporal decoupling would create a
situation where even if you were maybe
offline I could still get on with my day
and this has kind of reiterated from a
few different people
so Benjamin Johnson said that
synchronous communication is as a direct
communication between the sender and the
receiver
but with asynchronous communication
there is an intermediary involved
between the sender and receiver for
example a message broker this gets kind
of interesting
we look up intermediaries they are often
what we use to achieve temporal
decoupling
and as Benjamin mentioned they kind of
the most common example of an
intermediary might see would be some
form of message broker
so I'm sure some of hands up if you use
a message broker before yes look at that
right
hands up if you enjoyed the process
some of them are great you should have
you're probably using a bad one right
I love message Brokers as my kind of
I've used them an awful lot because I
often used to work in environments where
they were actually a core part of how
the organizations worked and were very
well supported managing message Brokers
yourself is often a giant pain so just
use managed Solutions nowadays and
you'll be fine but let's just kind of
work through for those who haven't maybe
actually used a message broker let's
talk about one of the most interesting
characteristics of them which actually
helps us achieve this property of
temporal decoupling
so you have service a that wants to send
some kind of message and I describe that
anything you send over message broker is
generically a message and messages can
contain other things so a message could
contain a request a response and events
or whatever else
so here I've got service a and I'm going
to send a message over a message broker
and I rather than going sending that
straight to B which is where I wanted to
go to i instead give it to the message
broker and say look can you make sure
this gets to be
so as long as the message broker is up
even if B was offline
I've still handed that message over
and the broker itself ensures that it
will eventually deliver it to service B
once service B is available and ready to
receive a new message this is the
property of what's called guaranteed
delivery
and if you want to know what guaranteed
delivery actually means for the message
broker you are using you're going to
need to look at the documentation
because they've all got slightly
different nuances about what this
actually means
but fundamentally this is a nice
property
in a situation where as another service
may be unavailable
if I have to deal with all those
concerns myself in terms of sending
service I'm now thinking about my own
buffering and retrying and cascading
failures and all that but if I can just
hand it off to a broker I'm kind of
happy I mentioned there are two sort of
fundamental truths of distributed
systems the first being that you cannot
beam information instantaneously between
two points in time the second
fundamental truth of distributed systems
is that sometimes the thing you want to
talk to is not there
and so having something like a message
broker which has been built to be highly
available
this gives us the ability to potentially
absorb that problem when our own
Services May intermittently be
unavailable for a variety of different
reasons so it's a nice property I would
also mention that the term temporal
decoupling itself has multiple different
meanings in different contexts but this
is the context which I'm using this term
A variation in this comes from this this
person who said the asynchronous
communication is like dropping snail
mail in a red post box
and going on with your day this is the
idea that I'm handing it off and I'm
going on my date there's a combination
here of I'm handing it to an
intermediary and I'm non-blocking so
there's a bit of a combination of things
happening here for this individual and
then one day boom
Postman Pat stuffs something into your
house mailbox along with millions of
coupons and charity mailers for those of
you who don't know who Postman Pat is
this is Postman Pat this is the OG
Postman Pat not that new weird guy with
the with the hovercraft this is the
proper official pavement pack so at home
I'm not at home right now as you can
tell this is not a hologram I don't have
I can't afford that kind of will I am
technology so I am actually here in
person but I have a post box at home and
our Postman who it doesn't look like
this he's actually got a beard but
otherwise it's pretty much the same look
right he has been delivering posts for
me and it's in my letterbox we have a
letterbox on our front door like I'm
sure many of you do here so when I get
home there'll be letters waiting for me
um it's unlike in the US of course we
don't allow people to come to our front
door
um just in case we like minigun them to
death or something so but you get the
idea right we have like an inbox where
our post comes and we're not there right
now but we can pick that up
and that's where the message broker is
doing this analogy of the intermediary
the message broker as a mailbox is quite
apt in that sense
I don't somebody else that puts it into
that mailbox and when the person is
ready to receive it they come and pick
it up
and there are lots of variations of this
kind of inbox style pattern using an
intermediary
you can use a database for this type of
purpose you probably shouldn't but I
know some of you have
file systems are commonly used as an
intermediary
in fact this is probably
the most common form of service-based
communication in the world
a large amount of systems that were
digitized you know back in the 80s and
90s digitized paper-based processing
systems and so what happens is now we've
got electronic versions of files that we
generate and we put somewhere and at
some point later on another program
picks them up and so we use file systems
effectively as our intermediary
you can also use email as an
intermediary based system for
communication between your services but
don't do that because that's silly
right
but the beauty of this model is that the
sender of the message does not need to
worry about whether or not the recipient
is currently available and that's a nice
property
of course what we do though need is for
the intermediary to be up itself if your
broker is down we're back in the same
problem as before
I sort of mentioned at the beginning
that you can use request response based
interactions can be synchronous or
asynchronous in nature we've already
looked at how request response-based
communication can maybe be non-blocking
but we can also use intermediaries with
request response-based communication and
this opens up some interesting questions
for us
so in this example here service a again
is sending a message it's sending this
case it's going to send a request it's
going to ask service B to do something
and so that request goes to the request
queue for service B so service B is
there listening waiting for like a
request it's like
is anything there no nothing's there
what about no no yeah yeah grab it and
he grabs the request and starts
processing it's like it's a nice model I
like I like this stuff it's cool so it
grabs that request and starts processing
it now of course it's got a response so
how does it get the response back to the
person who sent it the request
originally well obviously the answer is
always another cue so we take our
response we send that back on a
different queue in this case here I've
just called it the response queue and
now service a is able to consume that
response again when it is ready and able
to do so
this is an example of using an
intermediary based system like a message
broker to implement request response
which is something people are actually
surprisingly often don't know about but
it's a fairly straightforward model
but let's poke a little bit deeper
remember I started off by saying that
you used to be able to live as an
architect purely in the world of logical
architecture unsullied by concerns like
making the system actually work we can't
do that anymore we actually have to
think about well it gets implemented one
of those annoying details we have to
deal with is the fact that quite often
in fact normally in the case of
microservices especially if you're
running on the public Cloud we would
need to have multiple instances of our
services so in this case here I have two
instances of service a
so when I send that message when I send
that request to service B it does its
work its calculations it generates that
shipping label or whatever else and then
it sends that back to me over the
response queue
there's no guarantee
that that response is going to come back
to the same instance
now some people would see that as a
problem I see that as a benefit
what often people start trying to do at
this point is tie themselves in knots
that response has to go back to the same
instance that sent the request
why because what they're doing is
holding stuff in memory
so holding State related to this request
response based flow and they want that
response to come back to that same
instance
well that's the problem you've got right
there stateful processing
outside of a very small Niche you should
not be doing stateful processing like
that it's Daft right what happens if
that originating Services sent the
instance that sent that request crashes
if that response has to go back to that
instance but that instance is now gone
what'd you do
you also then have to add complexity
this is basically the equivalent of
trying to do sticky sessions
I think you said if you'll ever find
yourself implementing sticky sessions
you're solving the wrong problem
it's beneficial actually from a point of
view of system robustness and simplicity
to build your interactions when using
mechanisms like this to assume that any
instance of your service could handle
that request
that will simplify your lives greatly
but if we come back to our earlier
example where we're not using that
intermediary we've opened that
connection we're doing these
non-blocking calls and if we start now
thinking about what happens when the
service that sends a request dies part
way through
we don't really have a good answer in
this world
because here the way we've coded it the
response is the assumption is and how
we've coded the responses are coming
back to the same thing that send the
request in the first place because
actually we've opened up a network
connection we've opened up a connection
we've spoken to you and you're coming
back to us if we die that connection is
gone
so we've now got in this scenario very
much got to consider the problems of
what happens if the client dies part way
through
in general the way we handle this is we
just retry the entire operation which is
why it's essential to make operations
wherever possible item potent
and if you can't make your operations
item potent it's going to be painful
but it's arguable anyway that when using
an intermediary it actually encourages
stateless processing which is a bit of a
win obviously we've made our world
probably simpler to reason about the
downside of course is we've made our
world more complicated by requiring that
we've now got a reliable intermediary in
the mix
so we've got all of these competing
definitions we can talk about immediacy
how quickly is something going to happen
we can talk about temporal decoupling or
temporal coupling we can talk about
non-blocking versus blocking we can talk
about the use of in an intermediary
and it this is why I found this idea of
asynchronous communication so confusing
will a real asynchronous please stand up
and of course you might say to me you
know Sam does this matter words do have
different meanings
I the majority of you here I suspect
don't speak English as a second or even
third language but you would still
understand that in English as in your
own languages you might have the same
word but when used in different context
it takes on different meanings
does anyone want to guess stick your
hand up you've got a guess for this what
word in the English language has the
most dictionary meanings
good
yes it's set
so set has the most definitions most
meanings in the official oxidation
dictionaries that's the the big not the
one you get on your bookshelf right this
is the 60 volume thing that was the the
current version of which was written in
the mid-1980s the next version this is
going to be out in 2037 it's a
Monumental undertaking
um the in the new edition we believe
that run is going to have the most
definitions
so to give an example of what I mean by
having lots of meanings
set has only 430 meanings
whereas at the moment in the draft
Edition run has 645 meanings
Uh Kevin Henny actually did a great talk
at craftconf last week where he said so
the two words in English language with
the most meanings in the current edition
are set and get
and yet those are two of the terms we
use widely in Computing
and then we're surprised when people
find Computing confusing
right
oops but there is an extent to which
we're used to this
and ultimately we derive meaning from
these terms based on the context in
which those terms are used
I was chatting about your stuff at uh in
London earlier this year and Ian Cooper
who's also speaking here as well should
go see his talk uh obviously Ian Coop
has a hinterland uh some people's
Hinterlands are quite small Ian Cooper's
Hinterland is like bigger than my entire
life turns out that of course he studies
semiotics at University which is the
study of meaning right and he was
explaining to me that if you take a word
that has a very vague definition as you
put more words around it the meaning
becomes much more clear
so let's let's take a let's run an
experiment on this
so let's think about the word run what I
want each of you to do now is think
about what the first definition of run
and what it means to you
think about that in your head
I'm not going to check you working but
you know just go with me and now I'm
going to put some words around this
to explain what I mean by run in this
context and then I want to see if it
matches what you were thinking
the issue got worse the moment the
program was run
did that match what you were thinking
about were you thinking about run
maybe because we're in like a Tech
conference and maybe you were thinking
about run in the context of running a
program but maybe you were thinking
about something else
think about a different meaning of the
word run
and I put some new words around it
the economy crashed due to a run on the
banks
again
a bit topical maybe this is the
definition you're thinking of maybe it
wasn't
but if we were talking about the word
run without any other words around it
without any other context around it
there's very little chance that we can
guarantee we were talking about the same
thing
so again does this matter
the issue is that we throw around terms
like asynchronous
as though that word by itself has
meaning
you should make your programming
asynchronous we should use asynchronous
interactions if you're not doing things
asynchronously you're a bad person
says the message broker vendor right
let's come back to the reactive
Manifesto
they say that the Oxford dictionary
describes asynchronous as not existing
or occurring at the same time and if you
actually ask Google
what the definition of asynchronous is
it will say the same thing
but we've just learned that the Oxford
English Dictionary has multiple
definitions for words is that the only
definition it has at this point it's
very useful to have access to a full
copy of the Oxford English Dictionary
which I do because my brother's a
medieval historian and that's apparently
comes with the perks I mean they get
paid badly but they get access to you
know this thing and they're actually
multiple definitions of asynchronous in
the Oxford English Dictionary
in fact the one that is most commonly
used out there on the internet
was derived that meaning derived from
the use in medical contexts
so that was historically where that
definition came from and the full arts
English dictionary on lines great says
all the footnotes of where these things
come from so the definition we are using
in a Computing context is derived from
something that's primarily used in
medical context which doesn't seem to
make sense in fact
if we look in the meanings of the word
asynchronous there are at least two
definitions right now that do come from
a Computing context
and these were not the definitions used
in the
reactive Manifesto interestingly enough
or in any of the books that I've read
about the use the term asynchronous
so one of these terms talks more about
asynchronicity within a single process
but there is one that talks a bit more
about transmission
so this is a definition
data transmission in which packets of
data are centered irregular intervals
with the start and end of each packet
being marked by specific signals
involving such Transmissions I don't
know what any of that means
this is ultimately coming from work
where we're talking about the
communication at a very low level
how many people here open up raw raw
sockets and craft your own packets over
your own networking protocols
someone up there does there they are
which burn them
PCP or UDP or we work at level of HTTP
or we work at grpc where we're hiding
all these abstractions this is a
definition about asynchronicity and
communication that is from way down in
the stack and as a result has no meaning
to us
the reason this is important to talk
about is because fundamentally software
is a type of socio-technical system
that's a very long word isn't it
socio-technical socio-technical from
socio people
and Technical technology this is
technology in the kind of the I think
it's the Greek time the term of
Technology meaning a complex system with
knowledge rather than what we think
about as Tech right this is the generic
kind of concept of technology and before
you start saying oh God no it's some
other woke left-fing tofu eating
wokarati Guardian reader coming out here
talking about to Ram politics down our
throats
actually the term socio-technical comes
from a study of coal mining during World
War II so this is a term that's been
around for a long time when you bring
people and complex knowledge together
it's important that those things work
together otherwise you know people get
crushed in the coal mine
we have to recognize that the amount of
software created by individuals is
vanishingly rare that the keynote made
that point this morning in fact I think
it's often greatly overstated how much
software is created by individuals you
think about the Creator that looks
kernel
he created the Linux kernel really what
he did was great job of was pulling in a
huge number of contributions from other
people to create the Linux kernel
this is overstated the vast majority of
useful software is created by groups of
people working together
and if you want if given this truth it
is important therefore that we know and
are able to communicate with each other
because if you're having a conversation
about
how to build a system
and one of your colleagues says let's
make this asynchronous
and you've got a different vision of
your head of what that term means than
somebody else
how well is that going to go for you
especially in an environment where you
might be working in a more remote
environment
or you have maybe fewer interaction
points where definitions become even
more important especially if you're
working over different time zones
and we know this story don't we we know
how important good communication is
it's in the Old Testament
in the Old Testament we have the the
story of the Tower of Babel it's
actually only three verses
and they talk in this in this those
three verses about the importance of
communication they also weirdly know
three verses talk about the importance
of having of new building practices that
enable them to build a tower at all
we're going to talk about the fact they
discover new ways of building buildings
in there but it isn't there right but
what was happening is these people were
building a big tall tower
and the Old Testament God said no I
don't like that
nope so he went down and they're all the
reason they're able to build this tall
big tall tower is because you know they
were all speaking of one language and so
God said don't like it went down said
you're now speaking different languages
now there's no actual explanation given
in the Old Testament as to why the Old
Testament God did this
um there's lots of kind of subsequent
justification for this but fundamentally
we do have to accept if you read the Old
Testament and the New Testament that the
Old Testament God was a bit different to
the New Testament God he was a bit more
firing Brimstone it's almost like an
inverse Daenerys Targaryen character Arc
like halfway through like you've got
different writers but anyway so it came
in you you went in and you changed the
languages so they couldn't communicate
and so the tower could not be built
and this is a problem
we use the term asynchronous and
synchronous and we pass it around in the
same context but we don't give it enough
words around it so we can effectively
communicate its meaning
so what concretely can we do about this
start by having a conversation about
what is it your application needs
describe how you want that application
to handle different situations
what do you want your application to do
when the server is unreachable
how fast
should your application be
what should you do if in a service to
service based interaction
does the client crashes how are you
going to handle that situation
if available to you use the more
explicit terms that we have blocking
versus non-blocking
that's a great example
say things like clients should wherever
possible make use of non-blocking calls
We should strive to run operations in
parallel where possible to reduce the
overall latency of our systems we should
use I don't know broker X as an
intermediary
these are concrete terms we're putting
more words around these ideas therefore
the meaning can become more clear
but do try and make it's not about just
correcting somebody else's meaning and
I've immediately contradicted myself
here because I did spend a lot of time
kicking the reactive Manifesto which
as far as I'm concerned it's more
punching across and punching down but
and the only reason I'm able to do that
is because the people who wrote the
reactive Manifesto put hard work into
creating it in the first place so they
have my apologies in advance but it was
an easy target
in the princess as bride
you know vinicus is corrected
Montoya says you keep using that word
I do not think you it means what you
think it means now in this context
we all understand what the word actually
means
and in Gary martyr is picking up vinegar
to say actually your understanding is
different to the rest of society
we can't do that with asynchronous
we don't get to say what asynchronous
actually means because there is no
widely accepted term or definition for
asynchronous in the context of
inter-process communication in the way
that we talk about it nowadays there
just isn't one
I did check Tannenbaum right latest
edition of tannerman's book he mentions
asynchronous I think six times in the
whole book he realizes it's a silly term
and he uses different terms instead
right
so maybe just when you're in a situation
when someone says we should make this
asynchronous just say to them
what does that mean to you
ask them what that what the meaning is
behind that word
because what you find might shock you
all right that's me I'm done I hope you
enjoy the rest of the conference I have
probably got some time for questions I
think I've got about six minutes for
questions uh if you aren't going to hang
around I hope you have a fantastic rest
of the conference I'm going to be flying
off in about an hour and a half from now
unfortunately time gets in the way but I
really thank you so much for coming out
today and um yeah any questions for me
I'm going to seek anyone got a question
No Hands no hands oh go ahead
so the question was Amazon Prime going
away from microservices reduced cost by
90 it wasn't Amazon Prime it was one
small part of Amazon Prime and it was
Amazon Prime moving away from Lambda
functions for cost reasons and I see no
problem with that whatsoever
people have P so I want to be really
really clear people think oh I must be a
real big Mike because there was this fan
boy anything everyone should use Michael
services so the people in my workshop
are all laughing right now right
um I I don't care if you use
microservices or not right uh they're a
means to an end I have I don't like I'm
not selling you a kubernetes cluster or
trying to ship you know Lambda functions
so if you don't use microservices that's
absolutely fine by me just just please
buy my book though because I have got a
mortgage to pay for I'd be really handy
um I do want just but it's not a
discourse around that I thought was
quite unfortunate and quite poisonous
you had people criticizing the team for
even having the temerity to try using
Lambda functions in the first place then
they were criticized for making a
mistake and some people were saying you
could have solved in about 25 different
other ways you're not there you weren't
there you don't know their context and
you don't know how they came up with
that decision
and the idea that when people change
their minds about how to solve a problem
and then talk openly about that and
share those experiences with you the
people then criticize them for that take
a long hard look at yourself in the
mirror if you're doing that because it's
Daft and all you're doing is ensuring
that nobody else ever wants to talk
about how they changed their mind either
so I have no problem with it I'm very
thankful that they shared it
any other questions
all right
okay I'll probably hang around here for
about five minutes or so but it will
will be that short but thank you so much
my contact details are online enjoy the
rest of the conference
[Applause]